un an
[Musique]
mais vite ce terme le duo
[Applaudissements]
david stern du lot
le
tesla
[Musique]
je vais dire drake aussi loin que je
remonte j'ai toujours su que tu
arriverais quelque chose tu t'en sortir
est là c'est la première fois que je
m'inquiète pour toi je peux te poser une
question indiscrète ici
tél
temps d'écriture à des chansons se
sentent pas mes propres chansons
pourquoi pas parce que je le sens pas
mais pourquoi que s'ils bloquent à tous
les coups ou presque les gens que je
rencontre me disent qu'ils aiment ma
voix mais qu'ils aiment pas mon physique
bon je te trouve très belle
et quoi rien juste au regard des femmes
à c
beau
g
voilà ce qu'on va faire tu vas venir
chanter la chanson que j'adore
non je suis désolé c'est pas parce qu'on
laisse moi qui te plaît arrête pas drôle
avec à moi confiance t'as rien à faire
d'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]